bonsoir et bienvenue qui est ce que
votre émission culturelle tout de suite
le sommaire de l'émission 20e édition du
festival du mois molière une institution
à versailles un mois de vie théâtre
cirque musique et donc nous recevons
martin comédienne qu'elle est en
représentation dans deux pièces
la chanteuse française de la célèbre
chien airs et des livres est venu aux
clayes-sous-bois points les fans étaient
nombreux
depuis tout savoir sur la prochaine
saison culturelle la scène national de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est dans la chronique de nicolas
jardin massey tas mais donc avant tout
cela je vous propose d'ouvrir une page
théâtre
le mois molière 20e édition d'un
festival qui se déroule à versailles qui
mélange plusieurs hasard et en premier
lieu évidemment le théâtre plus de 350
représentations c'est un peu le festival
d'avignon avant l'heure martine delors
bonsoir bon c'est vrai vous êtes
comédienne et vous êtes à la fiche de 2
pièces de pièces qui seront très
différentes
la première question qui on veut d'abord
envie de vous poser c'est est-ce que
vous êtes déjà venu jouer à versailles
dans le cadre ce mois molière
oui je suis venu il y a deux ans trois
ans quelque chose comme ça aux petites
écuries j'ai joué le péché la grâce
d'après d'après giraudeau écrire c'est
très joli là vous allez jouer à l'espace
se réchauffe est-ce que je l'espère un
peu particulière de jouer dans un
festival de ce type
ah oui l'effervescence en un mois dans
une ville
oui ça ressemble pas un théâtre cadre
est normal où on a ses habitudes déjà il
n'ya pas d'habitude donc il faut
réinventer les entrées des sorties des
fois il peut y avoir un écho puisque ce
sont des lieux historiques
donc il faut gérer les co pour que tout
le monde entende parce que donc il faut
il faut réinventer le spectacle et ça
c'est bien parce que ça évite de
s'installer on retrouve des émotions
qu'on avait peut-être un petit peu
perdues parce que parce qu'on s'était
installé dans un théâtre
et puis il ya un contact avec le public
les gens ce qui est différent que 21
points qui vient dans un théâtre oui
puis les gens c'est vraiment ils
attendent disent attendre deux mois
molière c'est très populaire quand on
dit le mois molière
les gens disent ah oui nous on n'y a été
une fois on a été voir si on a été voir
ça j'ai des amis qui ont joué au moins
un molière pas au même endroit mais tout
le monde garde un beau souvenir quand on
est comédien à ce que ça permet de se
faire repérer entre guillemets par des
programmateurs
on espère on espère toujours qu'un
programmateur aura la bonne idée de
venir voir notre spectacle mais c'est
comme un vignon c'est une loterie alors
bon ben voilà qu'il faut se dire que
chaque spectateur est important même
s'il est pas programmateur il faut qu'il
soit heureux d'être venu il faut qu'il
ait ressenti des fois que pour les
programmateurs je dois pour les
programmateurs ça c'est un plus et c'est
là que réside en plus ici alors je le
dis vous êtes à l'affice de deux pièces
à la première sera jouée le 13 juin à
21h à l'espace richaud c'est un nouvel
espace culturel que vous avez inauguré
en tant que comédienne elle concerne une
rencontre croisée très d'actualité entre
germaine tillon et geneviève de gaulle
antonio c'est d'autant plus évidemment
d'actualité puisque c'est ces deux
femmes grandes figures de la résistance
ont fait leur rentrée le 20 mai dernier
au panthéon vous vous jouez jamais en de
quoi parle cette pièce on présume de la
rencontre c'est une femme tout à fait
c'est la rencontre à ravensbrück de ces
deux femmes qui étaient résistantes
grande résistante toutes les deux dans
le réseau du musée de l'homme mais elles
se connaissaient pas ce moment cependant
à ce moment là par contre elles ont fait
connaissance à ravensbrück parce que
vous êtes animés du même esprit de
résistance
elle avait envie de se battre de pas se
laisser mourir de donner du courage aux
autres femmes qui peut être en avait
moins germaine tillion elle a eu l'idée
de transposer ce qu'elle vivait à
travers une opérette qui s'appelle le
verfügbar aux enfers les verfügbar
c'était laisse comme ça qu'on appelait
les prisonniers qui travaillaient qui
étaient disponibles dont les employés à
différentes tâches dont certaines
particulièrement horrible et elle a
transposé ce qu'elle vivait l'enfer du
quotidien sur des musiques d'époque des
musiques connues alors ça va de grande
musique classique aussi bien que deux
chansons populaires de l'époque aussi
bien aux réclames de l'époque parce qu'à
l'époque on appelait passe à des pubs on
appelait ça des réclames donc c'était dr
que toutes ces femmes connaissaient
parce que ces femmes se sont retrouvées
par infinité quand vous faut un
personnage comme germaine tillon comment
on se prépare à rentrer dans la peau de
cette grande résistante mais moi j'ai lu
j'ai lu les textes qu'elle a écrits à la
banque écrit germaine tillion
puisqu'elle était ethnologue donc elle a
traduit tout ce qu'elles avaient vécu
déjà dans la première partie de sa vie
elle a eu une vie riche dans les années
30 elle était une des premières femmes à
choisir un métier nouveau qui étaient
les technologies elle a écrit des textes
quand elle était dans les aurès
puisqu'elle faisait satin sa thèse là
bas elle est parti six ans dans les
aurès quand même dans les années 30 une
jeune femme et lui elle raconte qu'elle
habitait sous la tente dans des dents
d'espèces de grottes en famille que elle
était respectée elle avait aucun
problème avec les gens elle n'a pas été
agressée on ne lui a rien volé enfin et
c'est vrai que ça fait réfléchir quand
on voit dans les quartiers les petites
jeunes filles qui ont peur de se faire
agresser si elle se met une jupe
donc ça c'est la première partie de sa
vie elle rentre en 40 et en 40 et basse
et l'exode et la deuxième partie de sa
vie ça va être la résistance le camp et
la troisième partie de sa vis avec
l'algérie puisqu'elle va y retourner
puisqu'elle va être l'intermédiaire au
moment des événements d'algérie
elle va être envoyé là bas pour discuter
avec avec des responsables pour essayer
de servir d'intermédiaire de calmer le
jeu ne va pas le calmer mais elle va
essayer et puis la dernière partie de sa
vie elle va se compliquer dans des
recherches
sur le sort des femmes en irak que
contre la torture et puis engager à tout
ça et vous allez vous engager en même
temps en jouant justement de regarder un
extrait de votre pièce que vous avez
joué les régions à l'espace richaud à
versailles
je m'appelle geneviève la nièce pour la
mémoire
pour la mémoire afin que personne puisse
dire même si c'est vrai je veux savoir
mendel tenait son bébé serré contre elle
il faisait moins 10 les nazis ont dit
résiste à la défaite
ta liberté s'arrête c'est vrai voilà
pour cette première pièce très fortes
comme une crêpe il ya des voleuses oman
qui joue geneviève de gaulle et jason
cher apica qui joue l'horrible d'asie
tout à fait donc le 13 juin à l'espace
richaud la pièce d'ailleurs jamais
millions et jouer en ce moment aux
ténors au théâtre michel à paris dans le
19ème arrondissement
quel est l'accueil du public beaucoup
d'émotion on a souvent dans le public
des gens qui ont
entendu parler dans leur histoire
personnelle de quelqu'un qui revenu ou
parvenu et on n'a eu pratiquement à
chaque fois des gens qui viennent nous
dire bah oui dans ma famille j'ai
entendu raconter ça quand j'étais petit
enfin c'est vrai que c'est assez
bouleversant donc c'est assez quand vous
jouez aussi une seconde pièce toujours
dans le cadre du mois molière ce sera le
20 juin à 21 heures toujours à l'espace
les chauffeurs qui promet vos habitudes
une pièce autour alors c'est pas de la
maladie d'alzheimer est écrite par jean
luc que génère cette pièce traite donc
de la maladie à travers la vie d'un
ehpad un établissement spécialisé vous
jouer l'une des malades même question
que quand on joue le maintien
quand on joue à une malade d'alzheimer
comment on fait pour s'imprégner du rôle
il imagine une ingénue non j'ai lu
plusieurs plusieurs livres j'ai j'ai lu
premier ouvrage de vulgarisation j'ai lu
les livres des sorts laborde qui ont
leur mère qui est morte de la maladie
d'alzheimer de son fait de livres le
livre de la fille d'annie girardot qui
parle de sa mère et ses c'est
bouleversant lullier dernier de la fille
d'annie girardot parce qu'on a tous vu
des films d'annie girardot welte cuisine
ou allisson la plage enfin dans des
scènes du quotidien et et sa fille
raconte qu'un moment il s'est plus
manger un yaourt la plus légère est
forcément voilà on a l'impression
on a l'impression de voir ce qu'elle
raconte quoi ce qu'annie girardot elle
est vraiment dans notre culture
populaire
alors c'est une pièce qui donne aussi
j'ai envie de dire à réfléchir sur un
point de vue à la fois même médical
aussi religieux oui parce que parce que
bayal interrogation qu'est ce qu'on
devient après
parce que voilà donc il ya deux
confrontations d'idées il ya le médecin
qui a un point de vue assez pragmatique
laïque et puis il ya le prêtre qui lui
parle de du passage l'eschatologie pour
employer un mot un mot à mot savant
enfin voir donc
qu'est-ce qu'on devient qu'est-ce qu'on
devient après la mort le sens de la
maladie mais mais ya pas que ça il ya
aussi il ya aussi beaucoup d'émotion
parce que parce que comment comment les
proches réagissent quand il voit
quelqu'un de leur famille qui va sombrer
peu à peu ce que c'est une maladie
terrible il y à des recherches ya
quelques médicaments qui retarde tafara
sur certains sujets voilà on est en
pleine voie là on est en pleine
recherche mais ça avance lentement et il
est pour les proches c'est une chose
difficile à vivre donc il ya des
émotions du plan on va regarder un
extrait du thème en fait qu'est-ce
alzheimer qui sera joué le 20 juin à
l'espace richaud à versailles
en tout cas pour un malade d'alzheimer
vous avait du répondant
je lisais à la femme l'autre jour
profitez-en
vous n'êtes pas croyant que ce que j'en
sais je ne sais pas je cherche
c'est triste mais nord peut-être que
c'est un coude et communique alors on
rit aussi dans cet élément voilà j'avais
drama goual mais aussi dur et oui mais
comme toujours dans la vie on rejoint
ans rejoint l'histoire de germaine
tillion elles ont beaucoup ri toutes les
deux dans les camps ils ont imploré
aussi beaucoup mais la vie faisais que
me voilà il y avait des moments drôles
badens dans la maladie d'alzheimer dans
dans cette pièce il ya aussi des moments
drôles sais c'est pas c'est pas du café
théâtre
entendons nous bien mais il ya quelques
quelques moments tellement absurde et
voilà et puis ces personnages qui
existent
humainement moi je joue une des malades
qui persuadé que de gaulle est encore
vivant parce que puisqu'elle l'a vu
quitter l'irak
j'ai plus mais à la différence et ce
personnage qui est un peu été ré est
prêt à se battre jusqu'au bout pour dire
pièce pardon germaine qui y ont joué le
13 juin à l'espace très chaud et puis
alzheimer jouer le 20 juin toujours à
l'espace réchaud et puis je rappelle que
le mois molière c'est pendant tout le
mois de juin à versailles les
informations la préparation est
évidemment à retrouver sur le site du
mois site areva du mois molière merci
beaucoup à vous là nous restons dans le
domaine du théâtre du relm à settat le
nouveau directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bien de
dévoiler la prochaine saison de la scène
nationale
nicolas gervais la rencontre et
j'aimerais bien savoir moi ce qu'est la
saison prochaine au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cac a demandé
ma à qui revenait la masse est à nouveau
directeur du cas de 50 ans il ya des
lignes directrices en fait moi ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que on est ici
dans un grand écart au sens noble du
terme certains classiques de la scène
que ce qu'il s'agisse de danse qu'il
s'agisse de théâtre il doit aussi être
extrêmement attaché à aller à la
recherche des nouvelles esthétiques et
des nouveaux créateurs d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes tous les soirs que là n'est
fait dans les salles de théâtre soit la
recherche de ses classiques revisités
dépoussiérer soit à la recherche de ces
jeunes créateurs qui font la richesse
delà de la création et de la scène
française et internationale
on peut commencer par là dedans lac tout
simplement bien entendu l'issue du lac
des cygnes qui est proposée par le
ballet de monte-carlo dirigé par
jean-christophe maillot qui a également
fait sept aux chorégraphies là sur scène
c'est cinquante danseurs c'est à dire
qu'on est véritablement sur une grande
forme pour une oeuvre que tout le monde
connaît ça va être une toute première au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qu'à la grande chance de pouvoir
accueillir ce type de grande forme voilà
typiquement un classique revisité est
ouvert à tous les amoureux de la danse
d'autant que le niveau technique mais
également le niveau d'interprétation des
danseurs est absolument incroyable
c'est le mouvement de l'air le mouvement
de l'air il a été créé il sera créé par
adrien m adrien mondot est clair
bardaine ce sont deux
technophile mais pas que c'est à dire
que il crée une pièce qui est une pièce
chorégraphique
mais sur scène il va y avoir tout un
travail visuel qui va permettre au
public ou qui va faire que le public va
totalement perdre ses repères spatiaux
voire même temporel
tous ces messieurs ligue 1 qu'est ce que
tu sais que les femmes je vous aime
j'ai pas là pour ça et parce que vous
avez été gentil avec moi
liliom c'est une pièce de ferraille
molnar qui a été écrite en 1907 et dont
100 par un jeune metteur en scène il a
34 ans il dirige depuis un an ou deux
ans le théâtre gérard-philipe de
saint-denis qui est une institution
il s'appelle jean bellorini jean
bellorini il a un esprit de troupe
c'est à dire que il s'entoure pour ses
projets
quasiment toujours des mêmes comédiens
il arrive à faire de ce texte des
ferrari fils éric molnar qui est une
sorte de conte ou de fable sociale il
arrive à en faire un véritable théâtre
populaire avec une scénographie
incroyable on est dans une fête foraine
avec devant nous une grande roue une
vraie grande roue des autos tamponneuses
personne ne me regarder dans les yeux et
tout le monde regardait ma place pas moi
l'équipe en gris qui était assis là et
parcourez les listes d'employés de façon
très différente nous allons accueillir
une pièce d'un des artistes associés des
nouveaux artistes associés à la scène
nationale qui s'appelle cyril test et
c'est une performance chimique qui est
construite à partir d'un montage de
textes de l'auteur d'un jeune auteur
allemand qui a une quarantaine d'années
qui s'appelle folk richters ça va être
l'histoire de gens consultent en
restructuration d'entreprise pour qui la
vie professionnelle va basculer le jour
où il doit licencier un de ses
partenaires de travail de ses
partenaires de bureau sur scène vous
allez avoir des comédiens qui vont jouer
cette pièce mais en même temps cette
pièce va être filmée va être monté et va
être rediffusé en direct
cyril test mais en fait en regardant de
l'autre la réalité ou une sorte de
réalité cette pièce qui est en train
d'être joué
et puis l'image qui en est issu et qui
peut être totalement et qui peut
totalement transformer la réalité
non
le sony dans l'innovation
la double coquette 7 au début à une
composition d'antoine d'auvergne qui
datent de 1900 1753 et sur cette
composition de 1753 gérard pesson
compositeurs actuels vivant actifs a
décidé d'insérer des compositions qui
date d'aujourd'hui de 2014 le disque est
sorti en 2014
donc vous allez avoir sur scène outre
une chorégraphie de la chorégraphe fanny
de chaillé des costumes de la star
internationale de l'art contemporain
annette messager vous allez avoir sur
scène des musiques qui ont été composées
en 1753 et d insertion de musiques ont
été composées en 2014 c'est-à-dire à 261
ans d'intervalle ces glissements sont
extrêmement subtile
christophe cha sol c'est un pianiste et
comme beaucoup un pianiste de jazz on
pourrait dire et comme beaucoup de
musiciens de jazz aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'il a il n'y a plus de limite
entre le classique le jazz
le spectacle s'appelle rabique sun à
partir de films qu'il a fait de nous
qu'il a fait faire deux films sont
d'ailleurs très beau de se projeter sur
7 de sa martinique natale et à partir
des sons issus de ce film il recompose
sur cesson et recompose sur le réel
c'est à dire c'est exactement comme si
vous vous parliez là vous me posez une
question et que je suis incapable de
vous dire là vous avez fait soldes aulas
dans la façon dont vous exprimer et à
partir de ces soldes au delà je vais
composer une je vais composer une
musique je vais boucler cette musique
j'ai pu boucler votre voix je vais jouer
dessus
à pau
le passé
la saison prochaine c'est cent quarante
quatre représentations ce sont cinquante
spectacles
on peut parler des liaisons dangereuses
avec dominique blanc vincent perez mise
en scène de christine letailleur il va y
avoir un monsieur de pourceaugnac lully
molière je peux vous citer réparer les
vivants texte de maylis de kerangal best
seller sur l'histoire d'une trempe la
transplantation cardiaque et tout ce que
ça implique en amont et en aval qui a
été réécrit dans un respect total de la
de la langue de l'autre is par sylvain
maurice directeur du centre dramatique
national sartrouville et une partie des
spectacles que nous proposant les sons
prochaine qui ne sont pas encore créés
by ap le théâtre c'est catherine qui
nous fait une scène dans le kiosque on y
va c'est pas ok ça c'est très joli hâle
est le théâtre donc côté scène et le
théâtre côté coulisses maintenant avec
cette visite des lieux programmée ce
vendredi à 19h pour vous faire découvrir
tout ce que vous ne voyez pas lors d'un
spectacle un conférencier vous dévoilera
également tous les détails
d'architecturé de ce monument du xxème
siècle c'est gratuit sur réservation et
après le théâtre partent à la découverte
des réalisations des grands architectes
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines savez vous
que les architectes de la bnf du parc
des princes ou de la cité des sciences à
partie à paris par ont tous oeuvré à
saint quentin en yvelines visite
organisée par le musée de la ville
rendez vous ce samedi à 14 heures
attention la vie est dure trois heures
tarif 5 euros et puis toujours autour de
saint quentin en yvelines
une exposition de photos du territoire a
dit photographe amateur saint quentinois
sont mis à l'honneur de nombreuses
images inédites et révèle les paysages
d'oeuvres d'art et de bâtiments sous un
nouvel angle
jusqu'au 26 juin au pour l'associatif
blaise pascal à magny les hameaux et à
partir du 6 juillet à la mezzanine de
l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt l'entrée
est libre
la reine des neiges était ce week-end
dans les yvelines ou n'avez pas pu
passer à côté du phénomène disney
l'interprète de la célèbre chanson
libérer des livres et a donné un petit
concert aux clayes-sous-bois pour le
plus grand bonheur de ses fans mais
parmi ces femmes florent de parfaits et
william l je mentirais plus à l'est
la reine des neiges c'est elle anaïs
delva est la voix française d'elisa dans
le célèbre dessin animé de disney et
lorsqu'elle donne un showcase pour son
album de nombreux fans répondent
présents et cela à tout âge y a pas
d'âge pour le disney
vous êtes des grands enfants voilà c'est
un rêve non parce que voilà on a
l'habitude de l'entendre de là
de là à voir sur internet élaborant des
balais ont poussé les hypers journal
je la voyais plus inaccessibles comme
une sorte de star en fait elle est tout
à fait naturel ça sympa et si elle est
trop belle
mais il faut bien dire l'arrêt des
neiges le plus gros succès du studio
disney et surtout l'idole des enfants
brad poule elle a chanté revel la reine
dîner blanche-neige et
j'ai signé à l'aide difficile de savoir
qui étaient les plus heureux des enfants
ému de rencontrer la chanteuse ou des
parents ravis de pouvoir immortaliser en
photo ce moment nous avons posé la
question à la principale intéressée
les parents ont toujours envie de
m'adopter parce que je les rends très
calme d'un coup ils sont il ya plus de
bruit et c'est marrant et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas eu la chance d'y être voici
une nouvelle occasion d'en profiter
à
je
m
ses fans anaïs on poursuit en musique
avec une soirée qui vous fera voyager du
côté de melun l'océan indien avec maya
kamati une chanteuse réunionnaise majaka
mathy et gris écrit chante et fait
danser le créole chez elle présente
aujourd'hui son premier album à
découvrir donc ce samedi soir la
batterie de guyancourt tarifs à partir
de à 10 euros 50
et je vous propose un extrait de my
akamatsu
et maintenant dans la rubrique quel
cinéphile comme tous les mercredis et
tous dhabi tout d'abord vos avis de
spectateurs dans quelques instants
ils se font attendre les spectateurs de
l'ue à 117 suit depuis longtemps et
c'est très bien fait je crois que je
vais revenir pour voir en 3d
c'est sublime bonjour très bien je pas
été déçu super bien bien dans le dans le
premier on a vraiment l'impression de
repartir à jurassic park
une petite anecdote au premier à
spielberg super est vraiment à part
franchement les effets spéciaux sont
bien ça manque de réalisme par rapport
au premier parce que c'est plus des
marionnettes c'est des effets spéciaux
mais bon les combats sont géniaux il ya
bonne scène puis à lui m'ont donc
seulement ils nous embarquent nous c'est
un très beau film
c'est très très beau et c'est très bien
filmé et jolie comédie
sentimental
original et très bien écrite formidable
divertissant cela change un petit peu
c'est vraiment très très bien j'ai
beaucoup aimé c'est un petit peu déjanté
une façon de voir la vie cet homme qui
part comme ça
sur ce cette petite rivière enfin non
c'est vraiment amusant ce mois-là
spectateurs emballés place maintenant
aux coups de coeur bat professionnels du
7e art se soit aurélie sergent du bois
ni à celle de trappes
le coup de coeur du grenier à sel cette
semaine ce sera la loi du marché de
stéphane brizé un film que nous allons
diffuser pendant quinze jours dans la
semaine du mercredi 10 juin et du
mercredi 17 juin ce film a reçu très
récemment au festival de cannes un prix
le prix d'interprétation masculine pour
vincent lindon qui joue dans ce film le
rôle de thierry qui occupent un emploi
après vingt ans de chômage dans un
supermarché
il est d'ailleurs bien soutenu dans son
jeu d'acteur par d'autres acteurs qui
dans ce film sont un non professionnel
on a donc une ambiance qui est assez
réaliste dans ce film-là donc au niveau
des hôtesses je suis ou bien pour voir
ses escales tous les articles
vu qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de départs
en pré retraite
j'essaie de gérer du personnel il va
être confronté à la situation de
précarité dans laquelle il se trouve et
va devoir s'y confronter et avec
toujours beaucoup de courage réussir à
surmonter toute la violence dans
laquelle ce personnage est plongée et à
sortir d'un système qui ne lui convient
pas forcément sa première femme avant ça
mais vous avez été filmée j'en ai dit
confirmé thierry vous confirmez
et voilà la loi du marché avec
évidemment un excellent vincent lindon
c'était de mission est maintenant
terminé merci de l'avoir suivi rendez
vous mercredi prochain nous vous donnons
des idées à l'occasion de la fête de la
musique
d'ici là garder l'esprit ouvert et
curieux et puis surtout bonne semaine